trying to get comfortable Imran Khan a  star of sport and politics back in front  of the cameras Keen to share the details  of his injuries and Recovery  it's little over 24 hours since this  apparent assassination attempt  he was shot twice in the left and right  thigh his left tibia fractured  egg done  foreign  tear gas fired on the outskirts of the  capital Islamabad many of Mr Khan's  supporters convinced he is the victim of  a deep state conspiracy  yoga  this is  the government who he has heavily  criticized say they welcome an  investigation it was very unfortunate  and it was condemned across the board by  all political parties and also heads of  all political parties uh it is I think  there is no space of Bloodshed in  politics of Pakistan  the protests are relatively small but a  deep divide has sharpened and Pakistan  is polarized an attack on one of its  biggest names could push it to the brink  Cordelia Lynch Sky News Lahore Pakistan